It's official: fans are loving
the new "Star Wars" show "Ahsoka",
and they're taking to social media
in droves to share their thoughts.
Minor spoilers for the first two episodes ahead!
After the standalone series starring Rosario
Dawson premiered on Disney+ on August 22, 2023,
fans hopped on social media to discuss
just how happy they were with the show,
which takes place a few years after the events of
the beloved animated series "Star Wars: Rebels."
Led by "Star Wars" guru Dave Filoni, the
series also stars Natasha Liu Bordizzo,
Mary Elizabeth Winstead, Ivanna Sakhno, and the
late Ray Stevenson in one of his final roles.
So what do fans really think of
the latest "Star Wars" project?
After seeing Dawson bring the character into
the live-action realm in "The Mandalorian",
they're thrilled her solo adventure is off to
such a strong start. One fan posted on Twitter,
"The first two episodes of ["Ahsoka"] just
deliver on every front. Everything that made
Rebels so special is beautifully
translated into live action,
and the heart and soul of this incredible story
remains strong. Filoni has done it once again."
General Syndulla, it's good to see you."
"And you."
Another fan agreed, posting,
"First episode of ["Ahsoka"] is
breathtakingly beautiful and I'm
in tears with how well done they've
brought the animation to real life!
A sweet and fitting tribute to Ray
Stevenson and an amazing cliffhanger."
Another fan kept it simple
with their reaction, posting,
"Last night's premiere was EPIC!" Meanwhile,
this fan got much more specific, writing,
"I think one thing I really loved about the first
2 episodes of ["Ahsoka"] is that the show really
isn't afraid to take its time. Each scene and
moment [feels] appropriately drawn out and we
get to sit with the characters for longer
than any moments in Mando ever allowed."
"You're gonna want to hear what she has to say."
Dawson already charmed audiences in
"The Mandalorian," and as a result,
she's built up a lot of goodwill as the
character — which this fan made clear.
"I just watched the first 2 episodes of
Ahsoka and holy sh*t how good Rosario
Dawson is leaning into this role [...]
The best piece of media so far this year."
Another fan made it clear that even
if you're not a "Star Wars" expert,
there's something for everyone on this show:
"I honestly think the first 2 episodes of
["Ahsoka"] do a great job introducing all
the main story beats and characters to prep anyone
to be able to understand and enjoy it even
if you haven't seen Rebels or Clone Wars."
There's even something for "Star Wars"
fans who have serious franchise fatigue,
according to this fan, who posted,
"I actually like it a lot so far and I've been
super critical of Disney canon for the most part."
Translating a beloved animated show into
live-action could have been a tough feat,
but clearly, Filoni and his cast met this
challenge head-on. As one excited fan wrote,
"The first two episodes of ["Ahsoka"]
were so freaking good like imo this
is already some of the best Star Wars
content. POETIC CINEMA The Star Wars
Rebels solidarity! Man I cannot
wait for more episodes to come."
Another fan agreed, saying,
"I didn't want ["Ahsoka"] episode 2 to end. This
felt like live action REBELS, especially with the
music. CHOPPER BABY!!! The casting is perfect.
Sabine Wren being Ahsoka's apprentice is epic."
"Nice hair cut."
"It's more me."
Some fans just felt elated seeing their favorite
characters make the leap from
animation to live-action:
"I can't explain the serotonin rush I
get watching Ahsoka and seeing Hera,
Sabine and Lothal in live-action. So
impressed with how good it is so far."
Decider writer Meghan O'Keefe posted that fans
of the latest major "Star Wars" project, "Andor",
might take issue with "Ahsoka,"
but she liked it all the same.
"Initial ["Ahsoka"] thoughts: Dave Filoni lovingly
brings his rebels to life in a story that embraces
mythology, magic, and lore in a way that could
turn off, say, ANDOR fans. Slower paced than
expected but still enthralling for this Rebels
fan. Natasha Liu Bordizzo is my early MVP."
Other fans were relieved that Ahsoka,
who wasn't wildly popular at first,
is finally getting her due,
like this fan, who posted,
"Well it took 15 years but I've finally seen
the introduction of Ahsoka Tano who went from
a character Star Wars fans initially hated to one
of the most beloved characters in the franchise."
The bottom line is this: fans
really, really like "Ahsoka."
Even diehard "Star Wars" fans are
on board. YouTuber StarWarsTheory,
who's definitely an expert in the field, gave
the series his seal of approval, posting,
"Just watched Ahsoka again to complete
my breakdown of episodes 1 + 2 and I like
it even more the second time around."
The first two episodes of "Ahsoka"
are streaming on Disney+ now,
and new episodes drop on
the service every Tuesday.